all right guys
bang bang i've got ben here with me uh
super excited to do this thank you
uh so much for coming on thank you for
having me absolutely so
uh ben is uh one of the rare people who
gets to write about the nba all day
uh and then spend his time learning
about that he also uh for those that are
watching this rather than listening
wrote this awesome book the hot hand
that we'll get into but uh maybe ben
before
we get into the book let's talk about
your background and uh kind of how you
uh
started covering the nba sure well
mostly by blackmail which is how i got
my job at the wall street journal um
i went to duke which is rumored to be
pretty good at basketball and
wrote a lot about sports while i was in
college and i sort of lucked my way into
an internship at the wall street journal
right around the time when the journal
was launching a sports page
in 2010 and i wrote a bunch of stories
that summer i kind of kept my foot in
the door
i was hired on a full-time basis a few
years later
and then i started writing about the mba
in july
2014 which i remember very specifically
because it was the day before
lebron james chose to go back to
cleveland
from miami and to this day i'm pretty
sure it's because
our sports editor looked around the room
realized that we did not have a
full-time national nba reporter at the
time
and thought oh my god we have nobody to
write this story
tomorrow when lebron james decides to go
back to cleveland
let me just let me look around and i was
the first person he saw but
it was a really brilliant time to start
covering the nba because if you think
about what happened
right around that time i still have not
covered in nba finals that the golden
state warriors did not
play in so it was right around the time
the league was
changing in a really interesting way um
my first four years covering the league
were all warriors cavs steph curry vs
lebron james
last year was toronto and we've seen um
sort of a reshaping of the league this
season before the whole league shut down
but
um it's it's i i sort of couldn't have
um had any better timing
and it was by complete chance like total
coincidence nothing to do with
me and i've just sort of been trying to
ride that wave ever since
i love that so was the first story you
wrote for the wall street journal in
terms of like
on the actual national basketball beat
about lebron james going back to
cleveland
in that new job it was yeah i mean it
was it was
uh it was it was kind of crazy right and
but one of the first stories i remember
doing that first season that i covered
the league
was about this guy named steph curry who
was very clearly becoming a superstar
and i think since then i have probably
written
about as much about steph curry as like
our finance reporters right about
goldman sachs i mean
my coverage of the league really has
been steph curry lebron james
and james harden um for a bunch of
different reasons i think all of those
guys are really interesting
in their own ways and they sort of
reveal a lot about where basketball is
today and where the league is going but
to watch a revolution in real time and
to sort of
have an excuse to write about what is
happening and just the
incredible shifts in the way that
basketball has played and
how like 40 years of orthodoxy can get
thrown out the window to the point that
the way that the game looks now
is almost barely recognizable from where
it was
five six seven eight nine ten years ago
it's really cool to write about that and
to try to find
ways to write about these global
celebrities that we all watch on
national television every night and to
try to find
new things to write about them after all
this time
i love it man and it's very obvious that
you're you're passionate about this how
is it writing about sports
in a non-sports publication so like if
you were at espn i'm assuming it would
be different than working at the wall
street journal
what are maybe like the pros and cons or
kind of how you see that that trade-off
so the way i think about it is that my
best stories the stories that i really
like doing
have to appeal to people who know
everything about sports and also
nothing about sports like ideally if i
write a story
it would um it would be interesting to
someone who has read every story that's
ever been written about steph curry
and it would also interest someone who
doesn't even know
who steph curry is or why the wall
street journal is writing about him and
so
um that's kind of challenging and um it
has really
sort of inspired me and prompted me to
look for
interesting um unusual quirky ways
into stories and so i have written like
funny stories about how the golden state
warriors locker room was
um in this civil war about um
their peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
being taken away
but i've also written like you know
hardcore stat nerdy stories like
explaining the value of steph curry for
example
um it turns out when you write about the
same teams over and over and you're
looking for new ways to explain
why they're good and how they're good
and and you know what made them good
you have to look for all types of
different directions but i think you're
exactly right like writing about sports
and writing about the nba for the wall
street journal is
just totally different from doing it
just about anywhere else
on earth because there has to be some
sort of
quantitative backing to almost every
story that we do
even like the funny weird stories like
you know players revolting about peanut
butter and jellies
what made that story interesting was the
tension
that like is rooted in numbers right
what made that story interesting was
that at the time that the biggest
problem for the golden state warriors
was their lack of pb js in the locker
room they were like 41 and 4
on the court they had no problems right
it was a very first world golden state
warriors problem and
if it's just a random nba team who cares
right um
what made it interesting was that this
team was so
transcendent that the only thing they
could really find to complain about
was not having peanut butter and jellies
on the team plane and so
um that that's cool for me because i
always have to be thinking like
is this interesting to me who spends all
day on nba twitter and listening
to nba podcasts and talking to nba
people and is this interesting to my mom
right who only follows the nba through
my stories
yeah and the whole idea of like this
quantitative view of the world you
recently wrote this article about uh
how much the guy who's guarding james
harden's getting paid like
talk a little bit about where does
something like that uh come from in
terms of an idea
and then what's the work that goes into
actually producing a piece of content
like that
so the guy who is guarding james harden
in the nba playoffs for the oklahoma
city thunder is this guy named lou
dort who just kind of sort of sounds
like an anonymous nba player right
um he was an undrafted rookie
last season every team in the league
could have had him and every team passed
on him
he signed a two-way contract so he was
in the nba and he was in the nba g
league
um and he ended up um you know signing
this new contract with the thunder right
before the playoffs
that pro rates out to 155 000
he's an nba player who's paid like a
first-year lawyer there's like no one in
the nba
who makes less money than lou dort and
he finds himself with
the hardest job in the nba which is
trying to stop
james harden in a playoff series and so
that one-on-one matchup is this sort of
mismatch for the nba
ages it's like if you watch that series
it is the most compelling thing
on the court because here is the
greatest scorer
in the world one of the best scorers in
the history of the game trying to stop a
guy
who is making you know 155 000
and so that that economic mismatch to me
was so
interesting and so the story that i
wrote was um
you know sort of crystallize those that
financial disparity that is on full
display
every time these guys take the floor it
also explains
that both of these guys in a funny twist
are more valuable than their contracts
every nba star on a max contract is
technically
underpaid he would make way more money
on
the open market if basketball were like
baseball and it had
a free market but his salary is capped
and his production is is far
greater than the 38 million dollars that
he makes but loot dort is
also valuable because he is playing this
really important role in a playoff
series and he's being paid
less than anybody in the league and so
um that was sort of the crux of the
story the tension like the
the um the quantitative part of the
story
and then the qualitative part of the
story is like well who is lou dort
like why am i paying i know who james
harden is who is this guy guarding him
and so that meant
talking to his youth coaches talking to
thunder officials
talking um to his college coast and just
trying to figure out like
how does that guy who gets
passed over by every team who is making
like no money for an nba player
end up with the most important job in
the nba playoffs
and so that whole thing it's like it's a
story that could appeal to someone who
doesn't know who lou dort or james
harden is because
um it's really just a story of like a
guy who finds himself
in this very odd peculiar position
in front of the world um but it's also a
story that hopefully if you don't happen
to know who lou dort and james harden
are you could look at it and be like
well i don't know how he got to this
point and also like
yeah what is the deal with like a guy
who is making
38 million dollars more than the guy who
is guarding him like how does that play
out um and so
that was sort of the thing that i wanted
to try to explore with that story
it's absolutely hilarious how much you
can
like okay who is this guy and then you
just described like this 360 analysis
for everything from how much money he
makes to
to literally what his youth basketball
coaches uh well it's funny too because i
mean you've had daryl moria on the
podcast and
i mean daryl is like the smartest guy in
the nba and probably the most
interesting guy in the nba the way that
he thinks
and um you know what daryl would tell
you is that like the way to win
in the nba is to just reap value
wherever you can
right so you get value from your max
players because
if if you could pay lebron james
whatever you wanted he would make far
more than the 40 million dollars that he
makes
but in a salary cap league you also have
to go searching for ways where you can
find
value in guys that anybody can get right
like james hardens don't
grow on trees so you need to get value
on
your mid-level contracts and especially
on your minimum contracts right
and like that is what the best teams do
the golden state warriors were built on
steph curry's bargain contract
like he had bum ankles he wasn't paid
that much and they were able
to build the spectacular team around him
because he wasn't paid like
the first unanimous mvp in the history
of basketball and so
if you look back at which teams win
championships and why
there tends to be a financial component
to it
there are people on that roster and
probably people who are
producing um you know far above their
contracts
that explain why they are good so
walk us through like that same uh
thought process for somebody like the
golden state warriors when they go on
this like epic run how do you think
about applying that
uh mentality to that team which part
like how do you find value or how do you
find stories that people want to read
about them
so the values like everyone knows that
obviously steph curry right there's like
the players at the top that everyone
knows of but how do you look at like
building out the rest of the team and
how important those players are
for them to actually go on the epic run
they went on versus just oh you've got
four of the best players and they're all
in the same team so of course they're
gonna win
so the amazing thing about the warriors
is that they were entirely built on
financial values so like steph curry
signs a new contract in 2012
his rookie extension he has bum ankles
he is not yet
the superstar that we have all come to
know and most of us love
he is not even an all-star but when the
warriors present him with this contract
a four-year 44 million
offer they both think they can get value
out of that it's life-changing money for
steph curry and it's not yet clear that
he is worth more than that
but it's also a pretty big risk for the
warriors because if his ankles don't
hold up then they are overpaying for a
guy who can't play so
what happens over the course of those
four years steph curry becomes
a revolutionary basketball player he
becomes an mvp in 2015 when the warriors
win their first championship
he becomes the first unanimous mvp in
the history of basketball in 2016 when
the warriors win a record 73 games and
like
the entire team is built around the fact
that their best player
is a bargain like in 2017
i think steph curry was not even in the
top 75
players in terms of contracts in the nba
and so
then you look at well then what happens
in 2016.
well they're not paying their best
player all that much money and there is
this infusion of money from a new
national television contract that kicks
in where suddenly every team has a pile
of cash
that they can spend however they want it
because the salary cap shot up
by 35 in one year instead of being
smoothed in
over a certain number of years there was
this spike and
how does every team spend this pile of
cash well
they all want to just lavish money and
the top free agents
that happened to be the summer when
kevin durant was the best free agent on
the market
and which team suddenly has the money to
afford signing kevin durant
the golden state warriors so because
steph curry is making you know
much less money than he should be given
his production and because
every team suddenly lucks into this pile
of cash in this one summer this one
anomalous
spike they are able to have steph curry
and kevin durant and klay thompson and
draymond green on the same team
and they send half the league into
hibernation for the next three years and
win
three titles in five years so all of
that like
they play a revolutionary style of
basketball they are thrilling to watch
like
i still think there is nothing more
magical than watching steph curry
play basketball but the whole thing has
this odd financial underpinning that you
wouldn't really um find unless you knew
how to look for it like
they don't exist if not for um this
trick
of financial accounting in this very
strange way
when uh when people talk about the
golden state warriors and kind of they
were playing just that style of
basketball it reminded me of the
equivalent being the uh the greatest
show on turf when the st louis rams were
just you know
lightened people up it just felt like
you know they were doing the same thing
just on a basketball court right it's
true yeah and and
you know the thing that i love about the
warriors and the rockets too and what
daryl has done in houston is that they
have taken advantage of the three-point
shot right
so when the three-pointer came in in
1980
nba teams dismissed it as a gimmick i
think it was like
two percent of shots that year or threes
they just were not comfortable
using it and slowly that started to
change and they realized
the value of this shot but something
funny happened from
2008 until 2012 which is that nba teams
appeared to find
the right equilibrium they had settled
on like
22 percent of shots were three-pointers
and it stayed at almost exactly 22
for five seasons it was as if they had
all realized okay like one out of every
shot
every one of every five shots on a
basketball court should be a three
pointer
and then like something happened that
they all just realized oh no
like that's wrong like we need to be
taking more threes and i think that
that ratio now is like i think the rate
is like 37 percent of shots
r3s the rockets take more than half of
their shots from behind the three-point
line they're literally
over 50 and the thing that has always
bugged me is this mystery of modern
basketball
what took them so long like the the fact
that the three-pointer is worth more
than the two-pointer
is in the name of the shot right it
should not have been really all that
hard
to figure this out and yet it was and
teams took a really long time to figure
it out
and what's changed in the last five
years is that
every team wants more shooting some guys
take lots of threes
lots of guys take some threes the best
players the ones who have changed the
game
are the ones who have figured out ways
to take new types of threes so steph
curry shoots off the dribble
and james hardin shoots while stepping
away from the basket
and damien lillard pulls up from 30 to
40 feet and
makes enough of them that it's a good
shot for him i mean this is really crazy
stuff that we're seeing
and it has resulted in a sport that
looks almost nothing like it did a
decade ago
can you imagine like our father's
fathers watching the nba then and now
watching steph
uh curry just you know dribble around
and throw up what looks like a hail mary
type shot with his
shooting form or a james harden
literally looks like he's running away
from the defender as he just throws it
up
like it literally is so different what
makes it interesting is that these shots
are efficient for these guys they are
such good shooters that they get
value out of that like last year the
isolation play in basketball tends to be
among
the worst plays like you don't want to
go one-on-one and take a contested shot
you especially don't want to do that
while you're 25 feet away from the
basket and your body is carrying you
even farther away from the basket like
when james harden shoots
he is stepping away from the basket like
that's never been done before and yet
last year
james harden isolating was more
efficient than the most efficient
offense in the history of the nba
the reason the rockets did it was
because there was a mathematical reason
for them
to do it and like those um breakthroughs
which
just seemed so counterintuitive um
that's part of what i love about
writing about this league is finding
those statistical anomalies
um and allowing the people involved to
explain them and like
how they realize that this strategy is
the one that can help us
win in the zero sum league when we are
all
objectively chasing the same goal but
only one of us is going to achieve it
every year
so one of the things around the three
point shot that you as a a former duke
fan will will appreciate that i don't
think it's enough credit is
when jj reddick was at duke he
completely
changed the way that i think people in
college
looked at a shooter right it wasn't this
kind of
uh let me spot up and shoot like i
literally remember him running
laps in on the baseline right trying to
shed a defender
catch the ball and he would catch it and
turn and barely have time to look at the
basket he would shoot
it would go in to the point where like
uh i'll never forget i think it was the
duke maryland game when he was maybe a
junior or a senior
and they were literally chanting on
national television fuj
right like i mean i don't think jj has
forgotten that either
but but it didn't matter right and so
like how much of that
plays into kind of the college game
evolving to some degree and then it just
carries into the nba or do you think
it's actually top down where the nba
game evolves and then it
you know kind of trickles down to the
college game yeah colleges were ahead of
the nba on this and
um you know i've actually talked to
golden state general manager bob myers
about this and
bob has a really interesting connection
to the three-pointer
um when bob was in college he played for
ucla he walked onto a team that
um won the national championship and he
is famously on the cover of sports
illustrated like
hugging tyus edney after his
coast-to-coast layup that
won the championship um but the next
year um
they were upset by princeton in the
first round of the ncaa tournament it's
one of these
great classic upsets of march madness
that like you still see on television
today and
um when they usually when when the
camera in that game
panned to the ucla bench looking for
like that shot of agony that they were
chasing they ended up
showing bob myers and he is chewing his
towel
in disbelief like how did we just lose
to princeton
and when i went back and looked at that
game and studied the box score it became
very clear how they lost
princeton took more than half of their
shots that night from behind the
three-point line
their coach this guy pete carrill who
was sort of this yoda of basketball
was one of the first people in
basketball to realize that hey maybe we
should
be taking more of this shot that is
literally worth more than the other
shots on
the court i think he once said like
they're going to give us one more point
like
we should take more of those shots and
so it was always sort of an underdog
strategy to launch
three-pointers but um one of the things
that bob myers who
literally built the team that changed
basketball by taking a whole bunch of
three-pointers many years later
realized in his experience at ucla and
playing princeton is that
there's a real psychological factor to
watching a guy make a bunch of
three-pointers in a row like sometimes
it sounds crazy but sometimes a three
feels more like four five
six points than three right there's like
a it's almost like traumatic it's
scarring in a little
in a way if if you see jj redick running
the bass line and coming around screens
and launching from 28 feet and switching
it you're just like
what do i do with this guy and um i i do
think that there is something
to that it's not quite the same as like
a guy making a mid-range jumper or
driving to the basket
for a layup when a guy makes a three
especially a big three especially when
there
is momentum on the line like that's when
coaches call time out and they're like
let's stop the game for a second right
it it literally is uh the dagger right
that's why they
they refer to it uh you you recently
wrote a book um
and i'm gonna read the uh the entire
title here because it's awesome so
uh it's called the hot hand and it says
what a billionaire investor
the best shooter on the planet the
search for a lost world war two hero
shakespeare's six-legged assistant and
one strange night in high school reveal
about how the world
really works uh talk to us a little bit
about the book i'm about 40
of the way through and it's fantastic i
highly recommend it for people
but tell us kind of what was the idea
here so this book really started
with two wall street journal stories i
wrote a few years ago about the hot hand
and the search to figure out whether or
not it's real and whether we should
believe in it and usually what happens
when i write a story for the journal is
that by the time it runs
by the time i have come up with the idea
and talked to people
and written the story and gone through
edits and it finally sees the light of
day
and people can read it for themselves i
am so sick of that story and i do not
want to think about it anymore
and the opposite happened with the hot
hand i could not get the hot hand
out of my head it was a story um with
incredible
stakes and tension and drama for this
fight over
an idea like trying to understand what's
really
real and it was a story um this like
generational saga
in which the main characters were nobel
prize winners and
nba superstars and i just found all of
this irresistible and i wanted to keep
thinking about it
and reading the hundreds of studies
about the hot hand and trying to find
real human faces to put on this
phenomenon and so that's kind of where
it started
and then it veered off into many
different directions that i could not
have anticipated when i decided to
actually do this
i i don't want to give away anything
that you don't want to give away so
maybe uh
how much do you want to say about does
the exists well i
i you know i even if um even if there
were spoilers i think that whether or
not the hot hand exists
is kind of in the hi the eye of the
beholder i think there are really smart
people
on both sides of this debate and it
really depends on what situation you're
in
and if you are in an environment that
rewards
belief in the hot hand and rewards like
behaving as if you believe in the hot
hand or if you're
in one that punishes it and so this
story um
it's sort of a whipsaw narrative that's
kind of what i was going for and i want
you to believe that it does
exist because i think we all do
intuitively feel that it does exist
and then i want you to sort of question
that belief and then i want that
questioning of the belief to sort of be
turned on its head so
at the end of it you're kind of thinking
well i've toyed around with this idea
and
where do i land on it for myself and you
know part of this book
is looking at those studies over the
years the last 35 years
um but also like being able to enjoy the
stories
the people whose lives um kind of help
illuminate this academic phenomenon that
some of the smartest people on the
planet
economists and statisticians and
mathematicians and psychologists have
spent
thinking about for almost four decades
like this idea that is rooted in
basketball and yet applies
to basically everything in the world i i
think i read in the book that
basketball happens to be this very
convenient excuse to explore the rest of
the world and i really do feel
that and there's really no better
example of it than what we think about
the hot hand
what's your favorite story from the book
well you know there are a lot i mean the
book starts
the first chapter is about um the
creation of nba jam and it's about the
hottest game of steph curry's
career and um that was kind of my
rooting in this book right like you know
i have
written a whole lot about steph curry
and i played a whole lot of nba jam
and um it kind of makes sense that it
starts there but
it goes into crazy directions very
quickly i mean that's the first chapter
the second chapter is about
um shakespeare's plays in a play gear
which i wrote
long before 2020 and it's about the
making of
the princess bride and how unlikely it
is that that movie was ever made let
alone became a cult classic
and it's about a 20th century composer
this brilliant woman whose music was
basically sitting
in a closet for almost a century um
because she you know was in an
environment that didn't allow her
to get hot and there are stories about
asylum
judges and there are stories about a
lost holocaust hero and how someone
how these two you know brilliant
researchers were able to figure out what
happened to him and
there were stories about a a lost van
gogh painting
and baseball and auctions and i mean it
goes in
there are lots of stories but the making
of nba jam and
what happened that changed steph curry's
life were are some of my favorite
stories in there
so uh my favorite is the one that you
start off with which is you basically
tell the story of how
you had the hot hand uh one night in
high school what does it say about me
that that was not my favorite story
to tell just kind of the high level real
quick because i think but part of what
um
you know look i read a lot of books
right and as i read through them i think
i usually put them in categories like oh
that's an entertaining book but wasn't
super informative or that was
informative not that entertaining like
this is one of the rare books that
nails both of them so uh this story
alone right in the beginning i was just
like oh i can't wait to read the rest of
this
uh maybe explain how you got the
hot-handed why you were so surprised by
it
well i was surprised by it because i was
a terrible high school basketball player
right i mean that that's the reason i
was surprised by it
um uh really pathetic at basketball but
in one
quarter of one game i scored more points
than i had in my entire career i think
it was like 16 points
i couldn't miss like i i just i kept
throwing stuff up
and it kept going in and um i quit
playing basketball not long after that
game
in part because i realized that i was
putrid but but also because i realized
that um you know never again
i would i ever achieved that state in
basketball
but having the hot hands stuck with me
for a very long time like
i had plenty of reasons to forget about
how i was as a basketball player but
that night was not one of them and um
i had this very clear recollection of
that game
and it's strange but i've actually
realized that it's not all that strange
because i think that
all of us um have brushes with the hot
hand whether it's in
basketball or another sport or work or
life and and those
experiences linger with us we remember
them because
for a very brief moment we are like
becoming superhuman versions of
ourselves we're transcending our place
in the world whether it is at an office
or whether it
is in a jv basketball gym with like
eight people
in the stands and i wanted to know more
about that feeling and
why it's such a contested disputed um
sort of devilishly entertaining
phenomenon and
you know when i started reading about it
um you know what shocked me
was the the highly counter-intuitive
conclusion
of this paper that was published in 1985
this real
classic in the canon of behavioral
economics it's a paper about the hot
hand in basketball
by uh tom gilovich bob ballon and the
great amos taversky of kahneman and
tversky fame
and what makes it a classic is the
conclusion that there is no such thing
as the hot hand it's simply a misreading
of randomness so what we swear to be
true
is not true and that was it was so
contrarian
and so delicious to me and so um you
know
there are hundreds of papers about the
hot hands since then because
of that really incredible finding that
started
this whole field and so once i once i
dove into that literature i
you know was just sort of swimming
around and you know refused to come up
back to surface because it was so
interesting
i love it where can people go find the
book anywhere everywhere books are sold
all right so the hot hand uh i rarely
give book recommendations but this one
makes the cuts so
you did a fantastic job i'm so glad uh
let's talk about
uh the nba bubble that is going on right
now
um how has that changed your ability to
cover things and then kind of what have
you seen from players coaches
and staff that you've talked with now
that the mobile's kind of a couple of
weeks underway now
well i'm not there that's the big
difference right usually
for the playoffs i would be in the arena
you can go into locker rooms before and
after games you can
try to grab players and coaches and
executives so
to have conversations that you don't see
on television that
um help me with my stories and um you
know
help explain what just happened on the
court um so
that has been a challenge for sure um
but it's also just weird like we have
there have been basketball games on from
noon until midnight playoff games like
that doesn't happen either so it's it's
a really strange environment
and there are just there there are kind
of interesting stories
wherever you look because all of this is
happening so quickly and in such an odd
environment
and with so much at stake like what is
going on in the playoffs now
has almost no connection to where the
basketball season was in march
when it shut down if you think about the
way the playoffs usually work
there is some sort of momentum like you
were trying to build
toward the playoffs at the end of the
regular season i mean
that doesn't exist anymore right um we
had some like eight
seating regular season games to bring us
into the playoffs but
the way that the lakers looked in march
has no bearing on like what they are
going through
right now in the bubble so um you know i
i
i think it'll be interesting to see what
happens when the games really matter
going forward when we get to the
conference semis and the conference
finals and the finals
the thing that's really been surprising
is how high the quality of play
has been these guys were off for months
some of them went the longest stretches
in their lives without touching a
basketball and
you wouldn't really know it watching the
game like even though there are no fans
uh even though they're in this
environment that is unlike anywhere
they've ever played basketball before
the basketball is pretty good and that
has been surprising to me um
and i think kind of gratifying as a
viewer talk to me about luca
and uh kind of his uh his rise um
of recently what what's your thoughts
there so this is luka doncic who is this
21 year old
superstar right really the face of the
nba for
the next decade and beyond who it's his
first playoff series and
he just looks absolutely brilliant i
mean he is a sublime
basketball player and there are
interesting things about luca
that you know you might not think from
watching him because
he doesn't look athletic right he kind
of moves
slowly and deliberately and he changes
speeds a lot but
all of that is intentional so i wrote a
story a few years ago
luca was 16 years old this slovenian
teenager
who was playing in spain when he decided
to spend his summers
flying halfway across the world and
coming to this small performance
laboratory in santa barbara
for a couple weeks at a time um he was a
kid who was working out with nba players
he was like this sandy haired teenager
who looked like he had gotten lost on
the way to the beach and yet
he was doing things with his body and
studying his biomechanics
and training in ways that like you never
see
for a 16 year old and part of what makes
him such an unstoppable offensive force
is actually
the same thing as what powers james
harden's game
it's his ability to decelerate he has
the fastest breaks
in basketball along with james harden
and once you understand that you can
kind of see
how um his game opens up from there so
his step back three pointers it's all
because of his lower body strength his
ability to sort of like weave and snake
through the lane and try to
find angles where they may not exist
it's because he has these biomechanical
gifts that are invisible but um but but
open up everything
about him so um so that is interesting
to me about luca and then the fact that
like
several teams passed on him is crazy and
and will only continue to look
crazier with time i mean this was a kid
who was the best player in europe he was
the best player
outside the nba when he was 19 years old
like
european guys get drafted when they
played like 10 minutes for their
european teams
he was the mvp of the euro league the
mvp of the euroleague final four
and he led slovenia slovenia to the
european championships
like the champion of europe when he was
18 years old he was
a generational talent in plain sight and
the sons passed on him after hiring his
slovenian national team coach
the sacramento kings passed on him for
reasons that i still don't understand
the atlanta hawks traded out of the
number three pick and they got another
draft pick and they drafted trey young
but
that allowed the dallas mavericks to
come in and swoop up luka doncic who
looks like he is the cornerstone of a
franchise for a very long time and so
one thing i did right before the
pandemic was i actually spoke with a
bunch of his
teammates from real madrid who saw him
when he was 15 16 years old and watched
him
develop into this you know the really
the best player in the world who was not
in the nba
and um there's sort of a bias in the nba
against some of these guys and
you think like well how good can he
really be and all of these guys these
american guys who were playing in spain
and playing the best teams in
italy and france and israel um i asked
them like
what did your friends say when you said
like this kid is the real deal
and all of them were just like well none
of them believe me like i knew that i
was watching the future of the nba
and i was watching him grow up and we
were just astounded
in every practice in every game and like
i i would just tell my friends like
you'll see like this kid is astonishing
and
we're all seeing that now i saw a video
uh recently on the mavis twitter um and
it's luca i think it said it was he was
14
and he's basically in a gym he's tied to
one of these like
strength ropes like the farther you get
out the the more it uh gets tension on
it
and he's basically doing drills while
getting
hammered with a uh like a pad
right so literally he's he's tied to a
piece of rope he's like
that's actually what it feels like to
try to get past kawhi leonard
well literally at 14 years old he's like
tied to the strength rope right and then
as he's going up for layups he's getting
hammered with this pad
and all i could think to myself was like
at 14 we were trying to like
find friends to go play you know
basketball like wait
what is going on here you're playing nba
jam yeah and so it was just
it i don't think i understood until i
saw that video how much
work at a very young age he did in what
i would consider
a much more uh kind of professional arc
right this wasn't somebody who just like
was good at basketball and just happened
to make it in the nba it looks like this
was
very intentional uh expenditure of
energy uh and focus
in order to be the best in the world
right but why and why was he able to do
that because he was paid as a
professional basketball player when he
was 14 years old he was not an amateur
he had no interest in going to college
he was part of the real madrid system uh
he was a professional basketballer who
moved from slovenia to spain
to do what he was so clearly gifted at
doing right
and he was able to travel to santa
barbara because
um you know he was not going to au
tournaments in
atlanta and so um it really is a
validation of the european model of
developing
players um but he's also just a freak
talent i mean when you watch him
the thing that i love about luca is that
you could know nothing about basketball
and watch him play for a few minutes
and you will just be drawn to him he's
magnetic
right he's a really compelling force and
the best players on earth are the ones
who sort of pass that alien test where
you can just drop anyone into a gym and
say who interests you like if you watch
steph curry
you cannot take your eyes off of him
when he is rolling right you just want
to be like
who is that guy and like why am i so
drawn to him and i think luca
is like that i mean he's he's 21 years
old
he is doing things he has never done
before and he's doing them in ways that
really nobody has ever done before at
that age and it's going to be really
exciting to watch his career develop
over the next few years
i mean 21 most guys aren't out of
college
right like it's nuts um you've also
covered a whole bunch of other stuff
during the pandemic one of them being uh
fauci and
uh and kind of his uh maybe intersection
with sports and
and uh in that whole world uh including
his um
his now infamous uh opening night pitch
where he uh i i don't know how to even
describe it he just didn't have a good
pitch i guess this is the best way to
describe it
uh talk a little bit about like what's
the fascination there why find him so
interesting
so i thought he was really interesting
in like january and february i was sort
of hanging on to his every word before
most people even realized who he was and
so on march 11th
which most people remember for how it
ended
right that was the night that tom hanks
tested positive rudy gobert has
deposited and the nba shut down
um it's harder to remember how it began
and it began with a congressional
hearing um
in which tony fauci was testifying and
um a congressman asked him um
this was this was a few days after the
ivy league had cancelled its
men's and women's basketball tournaments
whereas the nba
was playing games in full arenas
in the biggest cities in the country and
um there was clearly this divide there
right and so
the congressman said who is right here
is the ivy league
overreacting or is the nba
under-reacting
and tony fauci said in front of america
like it's time for the nba to start
playing in empty arenas like the nba
is not the one that's in the right here
and they need to
respond and um that was really
interesting right and so a few hours
later of course the whole season gets
shut down but
i just thought well who is this guy who
is like telling the nba to stop
playing um and of course he is you know
the nation's top expert on infectious
diseases he has served six presidents
over
three decades um but when i looked into
his backstory i found that he had this
really interesting connection to sports
he was a sports obsessed kid
in brooklyn he played baseball in
brooklyn sandlots
he was the captain of his high school
basketball team which is not something
you would expect when you look at him
and he's like
five foot three and 79 years old um but
so i called up a bunch of his
high school teammates and said like do
you remember this guy and
what all of them said was he had this
knack for leadership
and they all remembered this one game
that they played they were a terrible
high school basketball team when in his
senior year i think they were 1 in 17
and they went to the bronx they packed
into a subway car
and they rode to the bronx to play their
rival a school called a school called
fordham prep they were regis high school
this
free catholic school in the city and all
of them thought they were going to lose
the best player on
the other team was this guy named donnie
walsh who would play at the university
of north carolina he would play in the
nba he would coach in the nba he would
run an nba
he once ran the new york knicks right
this was the guy that they were going up
against
and yet on that team um because of tony
fauci's leadership
they won that day and all of them
remember that game to this day like what
reveals
character a crisis but also high school
sports like we all remember our
our greatest achievements and our worst
failures in high school sports
um and all of them to a man said i
guarantee you that tony thatcher
remembers this game and so
a few weeks later i was able to i wrote
the story i wasn't able to get in touch
with him but a few a few weeks later
we did talk for another story um and i
said listen i gotta ask you
um i talked to eight of your teammates
all of them
swore that you would remember this high
school basketball game from 50 years ago
were they right and he was like are you
kidding me of course i remember
everything about that game like
he was like listing players from the
other team he was like nobody talks
about these guys anymore it's like well
yeah nobody talks about them because
they were high school basketball players
in
the 1950s but it sort of goes to show
you that you can lead the country
through
ebola and anthrax and avian flu and
aids and this coronavirus pandemic and
yet you still remember your greatest win
in high school basketball
that is an awesome story and frankly
it's awesome that
uh the teammates still remember that
like you get the consistent story from
all the teammates not just him as well
right
it was it was it was incredible yeah it
was uh and and you know i think there is
um some sort of connection between like
you know that that
raspy voice leader in high school and
the guy who
we were all trusting to lead us through
this crisis now like there is a straight
line there this guy has been
the leader of a team that everybody else
has looked to for his entire life
that's awesome uh before we go to wrap
up and do rapid fire questions
uh bitcoin what what uh what's your
position what do you know what do you
not know
give us some uh some insight i know
almost nothing one of my best friends
from college
um is um worked at coinbase and um you
know is
is into it so i think at one point he
gave me like point zero zero zero one
of bitcoin as a joke and um i think i
probably should have held on to it for
much longer than i did but um you know i
uh
it was a struggle for me this sounds
crazy but as a wall street journal
writer
to write the finance chapter in this
book basketball was sort of a breeze but
um investing in index funds and and um
stock picking
took a lot of mental energy and talking
to people and reading books
and so um maybe the next one will be
about bitcoin i should probably just
listen to all of your podcasts and that
can be my education
well if you've got a friend who worked
at coinbase i'm sure that you've gotten
the hard pitch of you got to pay
attention to this this is the future
sounds like they even tried to like
overwhelm you by sending you some to to
really make you pay attention
yeah well i just dismissed him as my
idiot friend from college but that sort
of goes to show you how much i know
uh trust me for every one of uh of our
idiot friends who sends us a good idea
there's probably a hundred bad ideas
that they try to shove on us right
uh yes and i've gotten plenty of those
too
uh before we go uh two questions that
ask everybody
uh what is your most important book
you've ever read other than your own
well definitely not my own i mean it
doesn't matter if that's on the list
um probably moneyball i read moneyball
when i was in high school and in the
book i write a little bit about
something that i call the moneyball
generation these kids who
came up not having to change their minds
about the way that sports worked
moneyball was the way that sports worked
um
and to me just the the revolution that
that has
incited um that book um what it captured
i mean it's just a brilliant book in
addition to finding this incredible
story it's um you know just every
sentence is hilarious
the story itself is remarkable and i
think that book probably did more to
shape the way that i see the sports
world than anything else
i love that answer um aliens believer or
non-believer
so speaking of idiot college friends um
i was in an in i was in
a seminar in uh in college which um had
the greatest
rule that i've ever been a part of in a
class which is the first day of class
the professor walked in and said you
guys can
set the rules of this class like
anything you want to do
we will do um and he said you know um
i'm gonna leave the room you guys talk
about it amongst yourselves for 15
minutes
and figure out what this class is that
you want it to be
so he walks in he walks back in we have
this discussion and like the one
stipulation that we had was that
everybody got an at the end of the
semester
and he was like yeah that's what
everybody always does um
but part of that class was every
everyone had to give a presentation
about whether or not
um aliens exist and is there life on
other planets and
um i did not give the presentation and
there's a chance that i may have slept
through part of the presentation but
the parts of the presentation that i
remember were very convincing so
i do believe um in aliens or life
you know that is not on earth um
but my convictions are not super high
like i have not spent a lot of time
thinking about it and i don't feel all
that strongly
about it what are the answers you
usually get like what's the breakdown
by far the uh i would say 98 99
of people are like yes it is more likely
than not uh
probably the most popular reasoning is
like you know we would be uh selfish to
think we're the only people here the
universe is so vast right
kind of all the things that you would uh
explain what what is the one percent of
people who say there
there are no such thing as aliens what
is their reasoning
uh everyone pretty much has the same
reasoning except for one person
uh every single person pretty much says
like i'll believe it when i see them but
why didn't we discover that right so
it's just like a
like prove it to me type mentality um or
some variation of that
except for uh josh brown who uh is a guy
who runs
um a uh kind of a wealth advisory
service on wall street it's on cnbc all
the time
uh he for some reason randomly blurted
out and said what are you talking about
ghosts are more real than aliens
i was just like i love it i was like uh
do you have evidence of the you know
like
where do you where does that come from
so we had some fun with that but now
pretty much everyone's just like look
you know either they believe and just
think that you know it's a numbers game
and kind of a vastness of the universe
or people are just saying you know i
don't care what the data and the
probability is like
just i'll believe it when i see it i
wonder what like the rest of society
would say i mean you're clearly talking
to like a very specific type of guest i
mean i would imagine that 99
of the people on the planet do not
believe that there are aliens
oh i think it's the opposite i think
that actually oh yeah
and especially now like uh people
conflate a lot uh ufos and aliens
so like the pentagon came out with ufos
so like if you go out on the street
my guess is that most people be like oh
yeah the pentagon already like admitted
that
and you're like wait a second like no
they didn't uh second of all
you're you think that the pentagon
admitted that there's aliens but you're
not worried about that you're not
talking
i mean like it's like this weird thing
um and i also think
uh people want to believe like that's
the other aspect right it's like
there's a tv show about that i don't
know if you've heard about it but the
truth is out there and
um uh it's called the x-files it was on
in the 90s and
yeah i i have not watched but
i've heard of the x-files right um
you could ask me one question to uh to
finish up what you got for me
oh uh
well i you know this is actually
something i'm curious about um is is
there any sort of like
you know i guess we'd never really
define the hot hand but it's this
feeling that like
um you know when you um have made a few
shots in a row you are more likely to
make
your next shot um in basketball and that
sort of applies to life is there any
sort of hot hand effect
in um in bitcoin investing or how you
see
that market um i mean
just investing in general i guess
there's a lot of people who kind of uh
will get sucked into uh every investment
that i make
you know goes up in value right so kind
of this idea especially if you're like a
day trader and and
you kind of get on a roll um investing i
always
talk about like whether you're buying
stocks you're buying crypto whatever
like it's basically just a legal casino
right in terms of uh what's everything
going and you know
deciding which uh uh you're gonna put
your chips on you know on the table in
vegas versus
uh buying a certain stock like yeah you
might use different um
kind of explanations it's pretty much
the same thing right you don't you can't
predict the future and so
um you kind of look at a probability
right just like you would do in vegas
and so i think that uh the thing that
people
have gotten smarter about with bitcoin
because it is a fixed supply
is like how do you avoid that feeling
right because that's actually where
people end up uh
losing a lot of money right is you
basically you keep betting keep betting
keep betting and like oh i'm gonna you
know for sure hit this next one let me
really you know make a big bet and then
as soon as you lose discipline house
wins and like you know get back that
regression to the mean type situation
uh i think with bitcoin it it has
shifted
people's mentality a little bit uh at
least the like what i'll call
true believers where it's like don't
spend right
don't consume just like do everything
you possibly can to
uh hold um and almost like this holding
as a use case and so
it almost gets in this way of like how
do you lower time preference where i
think like the hot hand mentality
is much more of like a high time
preference thing like you know it's a
fleeting moment
right and so for like you you're like
hey that one quarter in high school like
let me get all my shots up now because
like you know next game this might not
be here let alone you know the next
quarter
and so like i haven't thought enough
about it but that's like generally how i
would think about bitcoin and like any
hot hand type of phenomena
it's interesting because the the time
element of the hot hand is really
interesting so my hot hand in basketball
was one quarter of one game right that's
like eight minutes in high school
basketball
the next chapter is about rob reiner's
hottest streak as a movie director that
lasted seven years right so how do you
compare eight minutes to seven years
the other thing i'll say is that um i
don't know if you've gotten to this
point in the book yet but i do take a
trip to las vegas casino and write about
um roulette wheels and the gambler's
fallacy and how that plays intoleft so i
think you'll enjoy that chapter
listen i am uh i'm fascinated by the
fact that
uh such intelligent people gamble so
much right like
like when you're when you're intelligent
you understand the probability and you
understand like
the advantage the house has yet you
still go do it there's obviously an
illogical explanation as to why you're
doing it and i think that that gets left
out a lot
that's one of the beautiful things about
the hot hand is that even after this
paper came out by
some of the smartest people on earth
right if you were to ask any basketball
player is there such a thing as the hot
hand
they all would have said yes so despite
the evidence that we had at that time
which has changed in recent years right
um sort of a similar effect has happened
where um you know
people have had to overturn conventional
wisdom again with this
really deeply counter-intuitive pearl of
wisdom but um
you know we were told that something was
true and all of us said no that's not
true and like
how do we come to that conclusion that
was something that was really
interesting to me
i love it um all right guys listen uh
please go get the hot hand
anywhere that books are sold an absolute
no-brainer
i really enjoy reading i think you guys
will as well ben where can people find
you on the internet if they want to uh
congratulate you troll you
or do anything in between so for
trolling i'm invisible but for
congratulations um you could find me
anywhere i'm at um
bzcohncohn.com and that's also my name
on twitter
and all of the other social media
platforms that we all hate these days
i uh i need to get the invisible uh
social media profile
that's a great idea all right listen man
thank you so much for doing this i think
people really enjoy the book and want to
get in the future
thank you for having me